welcome to drew's
love bug with me and garcelle and we
have some questions
from our vff's first joining us is
natalie from mobile alabama
uh natalie are you there yeah i'm here
how are y'all hi natalie what is your
question
so me and my ex were together for 10
years and we have three kids
um we were engaged and the engagement
was broken off
um i've dated on and off and right now
i'm struggling
whether we should get back together or
just co-parent as friends because there
was a lot of disappointments in our
broken engagement
and so i'm trying to figure out what's
best for the kids kid
garcia would you like to go first um
i think it's great when families feel
that they can get back together and put
you know their differences aside and
work on it
my concern is and listen i've gone
through that in my head going
do we try to make it work do we go back
what i'm
i was afraid of for my life that if we
went back together
and it didn't work out that's that's
reopening a wound that i feel like my
kids
um got through so you have to be really
sure
that you guys can make it work and i
would do it slowly and not tell the kids
right away
the last thing you want to do is re-hurt
the kids with another split yeah
garcelle like yeah completely second
and i couldn't have said it better
myself that is absolutely it
the concern is reopening the wound
for the kids but also giving them not
only a false hope
but then in the future having any lack
of trust
that the rug might be pulled out from
under them again
or resentment i'm scared of resentment
for them
being like you didn't try hmm
so that's like one of my fears is like
resentment from my kids
like you didn't try for us to have a
family or something like that
so well okay let me just say this
they're going to resent you about
something in life
just know that yeah i mean yeah
but i think also you are trying trying
as
co-parenting is trying you know
you're putting the kids first you're
doing things together as a family even
though you're not living in the same
house
i mean those are things that you can say
to your kids dad and i
are really trying to have the best life
for you guys and sometimes that might
mean
we don't live in the same place what we
love you i think reinforcing
that you guys are together regardless is
important
if you have unfinished business with him
though i think what garcelle was saying
is get to know this and finish up the
business
with him away from the kids so if it's
ultimately we're going to get back
together
it's that or we're going to take time to
close this up so
i'm as certain as i possibly can be and
to get that confidence
whatever you do do it with him away from
the kids
yeah that makes sense i agree with drew
do it
oh you know the two of you it's grown-up
business anyways right
the kids don't need to be involved in
that um garcelle and natalie thank you
[Music]